do you prefer playing a hero with a
villain what do you think
[Laughter]
i love playing the villain
maybe because i'm not one
or maybe because i am
i'm ready i'm ready for the dogs the
dogs are so honest as well you wish you
see how interested they are
we've got greyhound and we've got
lurchers
[Music]
ladies they're both ladies
oh you're another lady
you're doing really well
what's your favorite movie role that
you've ever played you don't care
i'm answering the questions but you just
come in just come here for the
sandwiches
what's your favorite movie role that
you've ever played the drop was a dog
because they got to work with uh
with three
beautiful
bulldogs well pit bulls and they even
let me take
take the dog home one night
yeah
maybe they didn't
all right
why do you love dogs so much
um
because they don't lie
they're just all hot on their dogs and
they don't ask for anything
well i'm far from trees
although i don't know how complex it is
to be a dog so i'm just assuming this
might be a huge assumption it would be
extremely
extremely complex
do you prefer playing the hero with the
villain what do you think
i love playing the villain
maybe because i'm not
maybe because i am
we're bonding here abundant
what's the most extreme physical
transformation you've had to make for a
roll
oh are you really interested
is it my answers you're here
is it the biscuits
i don't know i sometimes have to put on
weight which means i've had to eat a bit
which isn't really a struggle is it
eating and then
nothing's been that hard to do it's
actually been a joy
it's not difficult it's fun
what's your favorite bedtime story there
are so many good children's books out
there like so many and being being a dad
has given me like such a privilege to be
able to read lots of jordan's stories
which is fundamentally one of the best
times of day is putting the kids to bed
and talking telling them a story
but for me i'm into things like uh oy
frog boy dog
and uh you know
i had the gruffalo it's cool you know
yeah it's a classic now not classic like
when i was young
if you were a dog what breeder dog would
you be and why
um
i'd be a i'd be a
bit sir i'd be a bit to this in a bit so
that
the mongol like a bit of everything i
think
all right these dogs are gonna get
really fat and we'll have to like
rehouse them as walruses
[Laughter]
okay
will you marry me
is that from coral
sure
about sea dogs home do an incredible job
of looking after
stray dogs and dogs that aren't wanted
anymore
so if you love dogs
and you love cats
please support them
because they need your support
always
[Music]
my go-to karaoke song probably
uh what a fool believes by the doobie
brothers
aladdin i can show you the world
shining shimmering splendid
a whole new world
i'll stop